上のカレッジみたいだったらちゃんと自分でサインして契約書を交わさなくちゃいけないんですね
規則を守りますと 子供たちの学校の場合はね
契約交わすことはないんですけどね
でももしかすると親に契約を交わす場合もあります
日本はどういうふうにやっているか分かりませんだけど
やっぱりその学校によって厳しく親に契約を交わせると
規則の契約なんですね
そういうそういうことを破ったらもう退学ですよ
だから子供にサインさせたっても意味がないんで
未成年者であって法律的には成り立たないんですね
だから保護者には未成年者に法律を守らせる権利が
義務があると そういうことで
あの学校はまあ学校に子供がいる場合は
この保護者がサインして願書を出して
で 僕らにはそういうふうなひどい目に遭ったことがありますからね
だからどちら側でもやられるんで
親からでも厳しく言われるし
学校の方でもやられると
まあ昔ですからね 今原始時代で勉強したんだから
やっと学校で何か誰かが何か悪いことをしちゃったら
まあ保護者にクレームが行くんですね
クレームといったら まあこの訴えがね
だから悪いことをしたのはなんか保護者みたいなことになってしまっちゃうんですね
だから昔時代だから 例えば父親なんかはものすごい怖いでしょうね
それで父親に学校から手紙来たら
このあんたはこういうこういうことで
こういうあなたの息子はとか言ってるかもしれませんだけど
だから自分が何か犯罪を起こしたような
あれでしょうに そこでまあどうせ自分の子供がやったことということわかるんだから
この家の中にいるんだから
あれすごい怖いもんなんですね
もし学校からそういう知らせが来たならば
そこで親がちゃんとそれはもうちゃんと理解しましたと
これから厳密に子供を厳しくまあ戒めますということは約束してサインしておかないと
もう学校に行けないんです
次の日 一日なんて まあ学校帰ると手紙を渡される
これを持って行けと 次の日は親のサインを入れた手紙を返さなくちゃいけないんですね
だから教室の先生がこの名簿に名前を入れる場合はね
ちゃんと手紙持って来いと聞くんです
持ってきてないというならば
もう帰ってください そうでないと校長の方にまた連れて行っちゃうんで
大変怖かったんです どちらでも怖いんですね
親だからといって甘えてもらうことこれ絶対ないし
向こうは犯罪になっちゃいますから
こいつのせいで私何の関係もない犯罪になったと
だから家に住んでるものだから
もう逃げる場がないでしょうに
だから子供たちは大体それはすごく怖いんですね
学校だったら逃げちゃえばよろしいし
あの学校に行かないでどこかに隠れていればよろしいし
家からは逃げるところはないんだから
だからそうやって このまあそんな立場みたいなもので
まあちょっと必ずも約束
規則を守らなくちゃいけない
ですから こちらでは一番目にシーラヴィスッディ
もう学校に入ったと もう契約書を交わしたということになってしまっちゃうんです
それで心の準備なんですね
ただ規則守ったんだからといって
いい勉強できるわけじゃないんですね
それで心の準備をして
よし これから真面目に勉強するんだと覚悟を決めて
図書館をすがったり 先生たちといろいろディスカッションやったり
あの教室の仲間たちといろいろ話をやったりして
いろんなことをしながら
もうこれから勉強するぞということに
もう自分の興味集中しなくちゃいけないんですね
もうなんとかなんとかカレッジの生徒になったんだからということで
もう他の世界をもう捨てなくちゃいけない
で そこはチッタヴィスッディなんですね
心の清浄  [ no sound]そこでヴィッティヴィッティっていうのは
例えば学校と比べてみると
どんどん勉強していくでしょ
自分決めた分野で そこで今まで自分がその世界について何も知らなかったんですね
で そんな考え方ではダメだと
地球は平らと思っていたんだけど
それではダメですよと
やっぱりもういろいろ計算して
見えなくたっても丸いと思わなくちゃいけないんだと
そうやって考え方をきれいにしなくちゃ
なんて言いますか 成長がないんですね
そこで勉強する過程によって
あ この方でよろしいんだと
これで自分勉強したい研究の世界の智慧が入ってくるんだというふうに覚悟を決める場合は
このヴィッティヴィッティですね
もう心は決めた もう今
変な考え方やら もうすべてのものから心は清らかになってしまうんですね
正真正銘のその世界の人になる
例えば医学をやろうと思って
これに入ってしまったら
最初は音楽も好きでしたかもしれませんし
文学も好きでしたかもしれませんし
もう文学やるような気持ちで医学をやりたかったかもしれませんし
中途半端でいい加減で
でも一応基本的なものを分かったところで
これは文学的にやるものじゃないんだと
もう覚悟を決めて この方法でやらなきゃいかんと決めたところで
もう疑いは晴れてしまうというところなんですね
疑い乗り越えられると
それか次に自分がもう仮説を立てて
もうじゃあこれでこの研究方法でやらなくちゃいかん
それでその研究方法でやってみたところで
まあ卒業ということはなっちゃうんです
そういうふうな七つの段階であって
それには何の変更もできません
ヴィパッサナーに関するこの次のポイントは
このラッカーナなんですね
で ラッカーナっていうのは
この まあこれは無常・無我なんですが
まあ特色でもあって 本質ということでもありますね
意味としては で これは仏教の瞑想っていうのは
この凡河一流になりたいとか何とかとか目的ないんですね
ただ真理を知りたいと
事実知りたいんだと 自分に対して
他人に対して 世界に対して
何者か 偉くなりたいということじゃないんです
で そういうふうな人々にもこの瞑想できるし
もう一人の人々が世の中に出て
まあいろいろ大変だと
苦しいんだと 生きることはね
生きることというのはただのトラブル悩みばっかしですよと
なんとかこれならないかと
なんで苦しみながら生きていなくちゃいけないんですか？そうやってこの苦しみというものを何とかしたいなという気持ちでもやれることはできます
ですからヴィパッサナーの法っていうのは
人生苦しんで疲れ果ててる人々
逃げ道がない人々にもOKなんですね
別に苦しむとか何のことも考えなくて
まあただ元気いっぱいで事実知りたいんだと
という風なもう元気な人にもできると
そうやって万人にやらなくちゃいけないというかね
でもやらない人々は必ずいるんですね
まあ苦しいんだけど 諦めたんだと
そのままやるんだと 諦める人にとってはもう仏教は意味がないんですね
あるいはまあ真理は何ですかとね
私も別に関係ないんだと
お腹いっぱいご飯食って
あのよくグーグーと寝られれば
まあそれだけで十分や
という イタリア製の靴を履いて
もう街を歩けるんだったらこれで最高やと
思うんだったら その人々にも意味がないんですね
ということは この無知な人にはもう関係ないんです
そういうのは仏教ではもう無知そのものというふうなことにしているんですね
無知でない限りは 無知でない人々は二つに分けられますね
それは人生の苦しみにもう疲れ果てていて
もう嫌になっている 無知じゃないんです
じゃあなんとかならないかと
と やってみる もう一人は別に人生の苦しみに疲れ果てるわけじゃないんですね
元気でもう何とかやれば何とかできるということなんですけど
でもそれではもう我慢できませんと
事実知りたいんだと という元気な人々にもできます
とにかくこの智慧というものは知識主義であるかないかということは
瞑想にとっては大変に必要なことなんです
そこで次のラッカーナの事に入りますけど
これはこのこれからヴィパッサナーという領域に入りますから
この領域の研究課題なんですね
このアニッチャ・ドゥッカ・アナッタという
無常・苦・無我という
この仮説を成立するために頑張らなくちゃいけない
それは研究課題なんです
じゃあこれはそうするとあなたはこれから瞑想して無常を体験してくださいと言ったら
最初からもう何て言いますか
洗脳されているのではないかと
という問題が出てくるんですね
例えばこの瞑想をやれば
あなたには神様が出てきて
何かお告げをしますよと言ったら
それ洗脳なんですね そういうやり方は仏教は否定しているんですね
なぜならば 心に洗脳したら何でも現れるんだと
そういう働きが心にあるんだと
心っていうのは事実を知る機能ではなくて
思ったものを知る機能ですよと
人は嫌だと思ったら その人は実際に嫌になってしまうんだと
あの人いい人ですよと思ったら
その人はいい人になってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから 実際にその人はいい人か悪い人かと関係ないんです
その人を嫌ですよと思ったら
その人本当に嫌な人かそうでない人かっていうと関係なく
本人にとってはその人は嫌な人になってしまっちゃうんですね
だから心の働き そういう働きだから
この洗脳することは仏教だけ世の中で大変反対なんですね
マインドコントロールは
でも世界人類みんな必死になってマインドコントロール
マインドコンただそれだけやってるんです
とにかくもう他人をマインドコントロールしようかと
どんな考え方見たっても
もう単なるマインドコントロール
ものすごくもう世の中のことなんてものすごい嫌なんです
本当は 人とも付き合うことさえもできないんです
気持ちよくニコニコと笑ってちょっと喋ることさえもできないんです
もう完璧にマインドコントロールされてあって
こちらまでマインドコントロールしようとする
で マインドコントロールされなかったら向こう側が怒る
怒るべきはこちら側なんですけど
なんでそこまで言ってるのにあんたはもう信じてくれないかと
そうやってまたかえって怒られるんですね
ですから マインドコントロールされてない状態で生きることっていうのはもう最悪なんです
で そこら辺に説明しちゃうとね
もういろいろ話は脱線しますけどね
まあまあ ちょっとした例を出します
例えば ある国民の人々が他の国民の人々が差別すると
見下すんだと それも最初からマインドコントロールでしょうに
我々の民衆が偉いんだと
そこマインドコントロールされたら
自分たちのけしからなくどらないゴミみたいな考え方でもとことん褒めて評価して喋る
ありがたい ありがたい
そこで相手の情報が何が入ってもそれを貶す
これ学問の世界でも同じことなんです
自分の文化が偉いと思ったら
他文化をいくら研究したっても貶す方向で研究するんです
で 私が言ってることは一方的でいい加減かと
心清らかにして世の中にある研究を見てください
で アメリカから出てくる映画を見てください
完璧なマインドコントロールであって
全く変でしょうに そちらだけ偉くて
そちらが人殺してもそれはすごい素晴らしくて
他の人を人殺しても野蛮的でいけないんだと
そういうメッセージだけ
昔の映画だったら この地球上の他の人類を殺す映画ばっかりでしたけどね
どこかのもう田舎に入って
森の中に入って そちらにいる野蛮人をね
この文化人がもうちゃんと指導して敵を殺して
という話で 今はそれを変えて宇宙戦争になってるんですね
他のいろんな宇宙から出てくるなんか変な生き物たちをね
だからそこ場合でも アメリカにどこから宇宙船が入ってきて
みんなアメリカ人に大変な目をかけてるんだと
そこでもう誰かがガキが誰かがいて
全部片っ端から殺してやると
その場合でも自分のは一番正しいと
そういうのもマインドコントロールそのものなんですね
例えばどんな大学を卒業しましたかと
それで決める あれはマインドコントロールなんですね
なんとかの名前の大学を卒業したんだからといって
役に立つ人間になるかならないかとというふうには見ようとしない
どんな大学卒業したんですか？それによってもう決めつけちゃう
それで人間の自由がなくなっちゃうんです
そういうわけで じゃあヴィパッサナー瞑想で最初からもう空やら無常やらね
無我やら出しちゃえば
それも同じくマインドコントロールではないかということになりますけどね
そうマインドコントロールにならないために
今までのずっとアビダンマでずっと説明してきたんです
きちんと客観的に大雑把に勉強してみてくださいと
勉強してみたところで
じゃあ仮説を立てましょう
心ってどういう働きかと
物質ってどういう働きかと
こちら人の勉強じゃなくて
物質と心の勉強になってくる
そこも人間や動物やその世界ももう置いといて
で 因果法則まで出てきたんだから
分析論と シンセサイズですか
この 組み合わせの論ですね
その両方も教えてあげて
そこでまあかすかに仮説は立てられます
じゃあ一つ唯一のものと言えば言えるのは
今まで観察した全てのものが変化していくんだと
変化によって成り立ってるんだと
変化でなければ成り立たないんだと
それから大事な評価できるものは何一つもないんだと
すぐ消えるものだから
そこで空ですね 実体はないんだという無我ですね
だからそこで仮の仮説を成り立っておくんですね
無常 無常 空 無我という
次にアヌパッサナー アヌパッサナーっていうのは瞑想そのもののことでもあるし
何を観察しますかということですね
で 前の瞑想法に出てきたのは随念というアヌッサティという言葉なんですね
何か言葉を頭に入れてずっと念じる
仏随念 法随念 僧随念 随念とかいろいろありましたね
それはまあただ唱えるだけで十分ですね
瞑想としては そちらに知恵なんか入る余地はないんです
知恵がない方が瞑想しやすいかもしれませんし
そこでヴィパッサナーの場合は随念ということじゃないんですね
随観なんですね アヌパッサナーで観察していくんだ
だから観察していくんだから
一つのものを念じることは無理なんです
一つのことを念じているということは
観察しないということなんですね
例えば南無阿弥陀仏南無阿弥陀仏と随念すると
ということは 何も雑念
何も頭に入らないようにして遮断してやるもんなんですね
遮断することによって
じゃあ知恵が現れますかと
全てが知られますか？という疑問が生まれてくるんですね
だから何も遮断するんじゃなくて
追って観察してみましょうと
だから瞑想の世界ってそこでものすごくもうぐるっと変わっちゃうんです
今までのサマーディの世界とはもう全く違う世界なんです
だからサマーディ瞑想というのは一つだけ全部遮断して観察する部屋
自分のうちに誰もいないと
そこでソファに座って
テレビの前で本を読んでいるんだと
そこで子供が誰か自分の家に入ってきたんだと
それで自分が本を読みたいんだったら
サマーディの人がさっさと自分の部屋に行く
行ってまた本を読み始める
あるいは行きたくない怠け者だったらそのままで読む
それで子供が出てきてテレビをつける
それじゃまなんです 何やってるんですか？テレビ消しなさい
本読んでるんだからと怒ったりする
そうやって何とかの形で遮断する
それはサマーディ的なやり方で
ヴィパッサナーのやり方はせっかく一人静かに本を読んでいたんだと
だから子供が入ってきたんだと
何かまずは挨拶しなくちゃいけないんだと
そこは全部葛藤はもう本はもう読めないんだと
そこでお腹が空いた ご飯食べたいと言ったら
じゃあそうだったらまあ本は読みたいかもしれません
でも読めないんだ それ置いといて
じゃあ料理作りますということで
そうやって動くんです
そこはヴィパッサナー的なやり方なんですね
で 料理用意しようとしているところで
また突然電話がかけてきたんだと
2番目の子供はなんかちょっと怪我して学校にいるんだと
言ったらその子であんたこのコンビニでコンビニで何か買って食べなさいと言って
そこで学校に行く 何も遮断はしないんですね
その場でその場で行動していくという方法
サマーディの人 誰かに言ってくださいと
本読まなくちゃいけないんだ
お腹がすいたら勝手に何か取って食べなさいと
で この他の情報は受け入れようとしないこと
だから 私たちの人生の中で
我々はたまたまこの 2つともやってる場合やってるでしょうね
時々サマーディ的な生き方やってるわ
時々ヴィパッサナー的な生き方やってるわと
だからその条件によってやってる仕事はすぐ変えて
次の仕事に行く 条件変えた途端
またそれをやめて次のことに行くという
飛んで飛んで飛んで飛んで行くこと
がヴィパッサナー的というヴィパッサナーではないんだけど
ヴィパッサナー的でもないんだけど
似ている我々の日常生活なんですね
条件を変えて変えて自分の道を行くことはサマーディ的なんですね
ですから 瞑想のやり方はすごい違うということを理解してほしいんです
この場合はアヌパッサナーズイカン
なぜあのズイというのは
その場でその場で出てくる観察を観察するんだ
そこで仮説はあるんだから
ズイカンしたっても またちょっと問題があるんですね
例えば本を読んでいて
難しいな わかりにくいなと思っている瞬間で
もう子供がテレビつけたりする
あ この方が面白いや じゃあ二人でテレビ見ようと
そこで面白なくなった
じゃあチャンネル変えようとか
そういうやり方もありますけどね
ヴィパッサナーではそういうズイカンでは何も得られないんですね
例えば瞑想中 音が入りました
鳥の声で ああ すごく綺麗でした
散歩していると花が見えました
ものすごく感動しましたと
で 私のにインタビューに来た人々は
これから来ない方がいいかもしれませんだけど
そういうことをして言って
私に対して怒るんですね
何が悪いんですかと その素晴らしい美しさを感じて
だから何も悪くはないんです
それはゴミだけ その人は
洗えないんです だから私は怒るんです
もう洗濯しようと思ったって
ゴミそのものを洗濯機に入れたって意味がないでしょうに
洗濯機に入れるのは汚れているものなの
汚れてるだけで もともとは綺麗や
ですから そんな感じで何百年瞑想したっても成長がないんです
あ 音は入りました すごい気持ち悪い音でした
あ 音が入ります すごい気持ちいい音でした
あ 何か見えてきた すごい気持ちよかった
何か見えてきた すごい気持ち悪かったと
それは普通の人と何か違うんですかね
何も違いはないでしょうに
子供も同じことやってるでしょうに
だからここら辺 ものすごい鋭いっていう
徹底した鋭いこの観察能力必要なんで
最初からもうしょうがないんです
だからって音が耳に入った
気持ちよくなったということは
視線の流れでしょうし
その視線の流れを観察してほしいんだけど
それで何が悪いんですか？と私に聞くと
私は口では何も言いませんだけどね
もう結論はとっくにもう本人が私に言ってるんですね
見込みはないと だから 1週間に 1週間で心変わるはずなんですけどね
変わらないのはそういうとこなんです
そういうとこあるんだからなんです
大体私の話をあまりにも聞き過ぎなんですけどね
ずっとこの私の生き方なんですか？性格など私を観察してるんですね
一人も自分の心見た人を見つかってないんです
だから何年経ってもすごい安定していますね
心は そこは私も驚きますけどね
こんなに安定している心の方々はいないんじゃないかと
そのまんまでと そこでズビカンの場合はアニッチャーアヌパッサナー
このこの仮説はありますから
例えば音が耳に入った
すごく気持ちよくなったと
それを観察しておく ちょっと歩くと
またある音が突然 車のクラクションの音が耳に入ったと
驚きましたと そこでアニッチャというものあるでしょうに
ほんの瞬間の前で気持ちよくなった
次の瞬間で驚きました
びっくりしましたと 次にまた音を入るでしょうに
その時はどうしましたかと
それは何が悪かったという問題じゃないんです
ですから このズウィカンはそういうアニッチャの方向へもうちょっと持っていかなくちゃいけないんですね
ただそれだけですよと
瞑想中 ウグイスの声が入ったと
気持ちよく気持ちよかった
ただそれだけですと 次の瞬間には足の痛みが感じる
感じるでしょうに 痛みがあるんだと
そこは気持ちいいわけじゃないでしょうに
そうやってこの観察することによって
このアニッチャですよと変わっていくんですよと
アニッチャですよと思ったら威張ってることなんですけど
もうそこら辺 すごくもう微妙なんです
口先だけで言えるのは誰にでもできますから
そんなことは ですからこの微妙なんですけど
この変化していくんだという方向は研究課題でもありますし
仮説でもあるし その仮説を成立する方向へ実験しなくちゃいけないんですね
今までこんなに食べ物を美味しく感じたことがないんだと感動するともう困っちゃうんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想しながら一言も喋らないで
ゆっくりと噛んで食べたことで
ものすごい味がわかってきて
ものすごく感動しましたと
こんなに美味しく感じたことは生まれてからもなかったんですよと
涙ボロボロ来るんですね
そこで怒るんですね なんで私はそこは素晴らしいと言ってくれないんですかと
それはこのヴィパッサナー瞑想の研究課題とはずれてるんですね
その場合は そこは本人の事実ですから
私には否定できませんし
それは本人観察した事実だからね
今まで味わえなかったものを味まで味わってしまったと
で そこは真理だと取ったら
自分立てた仮説どうしますか？結論出せますか？卒業できますかね
だから素晴らしいという答えになったならば
自分が立てた仮説は間違ったということになるでしょうね
無常である 空である 無我であるという仮説を立てて研究しようと始めたところで
仮説は間違ったっていうことは
研究は全部無駄ということなんですね
せっかく学校に入って 年間の計画を立てて研究しようと思っている
そこで研究している間では仮説はまるっきりダメですよと
間違っているったら あの研究は全部無駄なんですね
卒業できなくなっちゃうんです
新しい仮説を立てなくちゃなかなかうまくいくし
ヴィパッサナーでは他の仮説はあるわけでもないし
そこでものすごい無駄になってしまうんですね
このアビダンマっていうのは
この人ではなくて この人に優しいという教えではないんだから厳しく言いますけどね
単なる科学的に論理的に分析しているものだから
残酷に感情を置いておいて
ですから この一応瞑想の働きっていうのは
そういうふうな働きなんですね
説法では言いにくいんですけど
そういうことだから 自由に観察とはします
その場でその場で物事は観察しますけど
驚いたと楽しかったと言って止まったら
これでは困るんですね
やっぱりアヌパッサナーは無常を発見する方向へ変化しているんだと
実体がないんだと 価値はないんだという方向へ持っていかないと成長はしない
次のポイントはヴィパッサナーニャーナ
それで正しく実験していくならば
正しく実践ですか していくならば
当然どうせ智慧が生まれてくるんですね
学校と同じなんですね
きちんと真面目に しきたりにのっとって
正しく実験して進んで研究していくならば
どんどん物事が分かってくるんですね
自分の世界では そのようにヴィパッサナーの世界では
すべてのものについてちゃんと観察していくと
どんどん智慧が生まれてくる
この智慧ってどういうものかということなんですね
1番目はサンマサナ・ニャーナ
サンマサナというのはObservationですね
いわゆるこちらは何て書いてますか？
すごいわかりやすい言葉でね
考える能力ですね 考えられるぐらいのものなんですね
あ こうですよ あ これはこうですよ
これはこうですよ あれはあれですよと
だからそれはどんな研究者にも
どんな学生にも必要なものなんですね
ものをObserve
それをObserveでは日本語で観察と同じことなんですけど
観察能力でもいいんです
サンマサナ・ニャーナは
まず観察できる能力がつくんですね
何でも客観的に見られると
主観的には見ないと この客観的に物事を見られる能力がつくんですね
だから皆様方 長い間瞑想実践しているんだからね
まあ時間計算すると私よりははるかにもうもう比べられないと思いますけどね
瞑想の時間は 時間で勝負だったらね
量で勝負だったら ですから
ご自分が世の中はどれぐらい客観的に見ているか
どんな瞬間で主観的に陥ってしまうかと
そこを客観的に統計的に見てください
1日中どれぐらいの時間
主観で感情で見ているんですかと
どれぐらいの時間 物事を客観的に見ているかと
その割り当ては自分の瞑想の進んでいる量なんです
何か神秘体験があるかないかということじゃないんです
よくもうそこは覚えていただきたいんですね
一般的な世界 普通の日常的な生き方で
例えば 1日とってみる
24時間  24時間の間で大ざっぱでもいいんだけど
自分が物事を観察的に見るとき
主観的に見るときと そこはどうせ人間だから
いつでも客観的に見るということはないでしょうし
すぐスイスイ主観的になるということもあるし
例えば自分持っている固定概念がありますね
固定概念というか ほとんど貪瞋痴ですからね
怒りか欲ですね で そういう自分の感情でもう判断してみる時とそうでなくて
あるがままに見る時と
一応 1日 24時間の間でどれぐらいかと自分で見てみれば
あ これぐらいはヴィパッサナーから智慧が生まれているんだということなんです
でもそれはなかなか本人にはできないんですけど
自分が実験台になって自分を実験することはね
まあそういうことでもう他人が